when you apologized for that all about
the Benjamin's comment you said
anti-Semitism is real and I'm grateful
for Jewish allies and colleagues who are
educating me on the painful history of
anti-Semitic tropes what did you learn
a lot I certainly did not or was not
aware that the word hypnotized was a
Trope I wasn't aware
of of the fact that there are tropes
about Jews and money
that has been a very enlightening uh
part of of this journey yeah it's been
so enlightening of course she knew
exactly what she is doing she's just
about like there's nothing we can do
with these people she married her
brother she is a really awful person she
has been all for defunding the police
she is absolutely destroyed Minneapolis
she hates America despite being a first
generation immigrant